The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: Well, so
three things to mention.
One was you remember last time
I made a list of six or seven
different situations where
Ax equal b and problems
that could arise?
The last one was when A was just
way too big to fit into core.
But in the middle
were other methods.
So other issues,
like the columns
being nearly dependent when
Gram-Schmidt will come up.
First, I want to say
that I know there
are typos in the two pages.
I thought you might just like to
see the very first draft of two
pages of the book.
People sometimes
ask me, how long
does the book take to write?
So I started when 18.065
started a year ago.
So I'm into the second year,
and it usually takes two years.
And the system is
I write by hand so.
I wrote those opening pages that
you saw, two pages, by hand.
Then I scan them
to Mumbai, where
my best friend in the world
types them with typos.
No problem, because I'm
going to make so many changes
that a few typos are nothing.
Anyway, so he scans
them back to me typed.
And then I start making changes.
If I'm lucky I'd have the
chance to talk about it in here.
Then I realize
better things to do.
Then I scan back to him and back
to me and back to him and back
to me.
So that's where the
two years disappear.
Anyway, I'm quite happy
with those two pages,
until I start improving them.
And one other topic from the
past that came out in class.
It wasn't in the notes yet.
Do you remember the day that
we minimized different norms?
L1 or L2 or max, L infinity
norm with the condition
of solving with a constraint
that this equation was
satisfied.
I'm in 2D to be able
to draw a picture.
And the constraint is one line.
And that's about what
the line looks like.
So I'm going to
draw here again--
what I'm doing is putting some
numbers in to that insight
I drew about a week ago.
Do you remember that?
Because I thought that really
illustrates how L1 and L2 and L
infinity are different.
Let me draw the L2 one here.
So where's the
point on this line--
so x has to lie on this line.
And where is the point
that has the smallest
sum of squares norm,
standard L2 norm?
So geometrically
where is that point?
Well, what does the set
of points with norm 1
look like for L2?
It's a circle, right.
So we just blow that
circle up or shrink it down
until it touches this thing.
And where it touches,
it'll touch where
the radius is perpendicular.
So there's our best point
in L2, because if we picked
another point, the norm
would have to be bigger
to go through that point.
So that's clearly the first one.
And actually, we
can probably see
what it is, because if we
know those are perpendicular,
I know the slope
of this line. so I
think that the slope of this
line is something like 3/4,
probably coming from
there, or maybe 4/3.
We'll figure it out.
I think it's 4/3.
I'll find that point.
Then the most interesting
one was the L1 norm,
because what was the shape
of the unit ball for L1?
AUDIENCE: A diamond.
GILBERT STRANG:
A diamond, right.
A diamond.
So the diamond that first
touches the line is here.
That's the winning point.
And if the line is
3x1 plus 4x2 equal 1,
then I know that that point is--
x1 will be 0 and x2 will be 1/4.
So that's the
winning point in L1.
And I think I calculated
this right that the winning
point in L2 I think will be--
let's see, this goes up to--
I'm moving down the line.
I think this would
have 3/25, 4/25.
I won't stop to derive that.
But at least-- yeah, the
slope is looking like 4/3.
It goes up 4 when it crosses 3.
And the 4 and the
3 came from there.
And, of course, you notice that
I've scaled it to fit the line.
3 times 3/25 is 9/25
plus 16/25, 25/25 is 1.
And finally, what
about L infinity?
What was the picture there?
What's the unit ball look
like in 2D for the max norm?
It's a--
AUDIENCE: Square.
GILBERT STRANG: Square, right.
So the square will hit there.
These two on the square are--
this is a 45 degree
line now on that square.
It hits it at that sharp point.
And so the x1 and x2 are equal.
And I think they're probably--
let's see, if they're
equal, if we made them 1/7,
then I'd have 3/7
plus 4/7 equals 7/7.
Yeah, I think we
make some 1/7, 1/7.
So that would be the
x infinity point.
3/7 plus 4/7 give 1.
So why do I mention this?
First, because when I did it
before I just drew pictures
without really
solving the problem.
And secondly, because in
thinking ahead about projects,
this is the kind of
project that I would
think is quite interesting.
Obviously, as this is p equal 1.
This is p equal 2.
This is p equal infinity.
And I guess it's pretty
clear from the pictures
that as p increases, this
point starts up here.
And moves down the
line and ends up here.
And I've no idea like what the
solution is for a different p
and how it moves.
And to make it more of a
project, what happens in 3D?
What happens in 3D?
In 3D, if I have one equation
in 3D, then I have a plane.
And this would become a
diamond, a 3D diamond.
This would be a 3D sphere.
This would be a 3D cube.
They would expand
to hit that plane.
And I don't know how many
zeros you get in that case.
So that would be the
case of one equation.
So there would be a plane that
these diamond, sphere, and cube
expand until they hit it.
Or you could have two
constraints, two equations.
So if we had two equations
and three unknowns,
that would be a line again.
But how many zeros would we
get in these different cases?
How sparse is L1 going to be?
That's like a recapture
of what we did.
It's nice occasionally
to have pictures
showing where the solution is.
Now, I'm coming to the topic of
the day, which is Gram-Schmidt.
And so Gram-Schmidt, number
one, is the standard way
that would be taught in 18.06.
So what's Gram-Schmidt about?
I'll just put down here
general facts of Gram-Schmidt.
We start with a matrix
A. It's got n columns.
But they're not orthogonal.
And, in fact, they may
be badly conditioned.
Columns might be nearly
dependent on the others.
I'm going to assume the
columns are independent,
but they might be
barely independent.
So those lines then would
be sort of like pointing
very nearly parallel.
But Gram-Schmidt
opens up the picture
to get a matrix Q, an orthogonal
matrix with columns Q1 to Qn,
which our ortho-normal.
So it gets a
perfect basis of Qs.
And so that's what
Gram-Schmidt does.
And these are different ways
to do it, different ways
to organize the computation.
I really only put
the standard way in.
What is this mysterious R?
So the Qs are
combinations of the As.
So there's some matrix to tell
me what those combinations are.
Or if I go back go backwards
and say, well, the As
are combinations of the Qs,
that's what I'm about to do.
If I say each A is
a combination of Qs,
that means that my
A matrix is my Q
matrix times some
R matrix, which
tells me the combinations.
When I multiply
by R on the right,
I'm taking combinations
of the columns of Q
and getting the columns of A.
So just like LU, you go
forward with the algorithm
to reach U. Here, we go forward
where the algorithm to reach Q.
But then when we want to put
it in one simple equation,
it turns out to be
better to go backwards
and say how is the original
A related to the final Q,
there has to be some R.
OK, I always feel when I
talk about Gram-Schmidt--
I usually end with
that A equal QR.
And, of course, the Matlab
command is exactly QR.
So in Matlab, the command would
be QR of A, instead of LU of A.
So it would give you Q and R.
That's what Matlab will output.
Now, as I say, Q is the
saying we're constructing.
R is the combinations that
we need to get what we want.
And so it comes at the
end, what the heck was R.
But actually, R is
really a simple idea.
So I want to show that at the
beginning instead of the end.
OK, so I'm going to move
Q over here, as Q inverse.
But what is Q inverse?
AUDIENCE: Q transpose.
GILBERT STRANG: Q
transpose, right,
because I've created
an orthogonal matrix.
So this mysterious
R is Q transpose A.
And let me just sort of make
it grow out into matrices.
That has the Qs along the
rows, Q transpose, of course.
Qn transpose, Q1 transpose.
I'm transposing the
matrix above it.
So these columns become rows.
Times the As, A1 to An.
So what is a typical entry in R?
That's really why I want to say
nothing mysterious about this.
You can see what
you end up with.
It will be right in
front of us here.
What is the entry in
row i, column j of R?
OK, this says that
all those entries in R
are Qi transpose times Aj.
That's the old way
to multiply matrices.
And it's the best way for
this, a row times a column.
In other words, the Rs are
just the inner products,
the dot products of the Qs with
the As, of the Qs with the As.
That's sort of like
nothing mysterious about R.
Because Q is an
orthogonal matrix,
we were able to put
it over here, get
a nice expression for R,
and see what it really is.
So you can do R at the
end or on the root.
But that's just the inner
product of the Qs with the A's.
Now, what's Gram-Schmidt?
I'm sort of thinking
you've seen the basic ideas
of Gram-Schmidt,
but let's review.
So I start with a.
So what does
Gram-Schmidt begin with?
a1.
It takes that first column.
So these a's are not
orthogonal generally.
But the first direction is OK.
I have no complaints
about the first direction,
except that a1 might
not be a unit vector.
So q1 will just be a1 over its
norm to have a unit vector.
The whole idea of
Gram-Schmidt is in q2.
So what is q2?
The whole idea is coming here.
It's the only thing
you need to know.
And the picture shows it.
So q2, I start with a2.
But it's not orthogonal to a1.
So what do I do?
I figure out the component
of a2 in the a1 direction
and I remove it.
So I take that vector away
and I'm left with this vector.
So there is a vector.
I'll call that A2.
So A2 is the original little a2
with the a1 direction removed.
So what what's the formula
for what I just did?
This is the whole, the key
step that Gram-Schmidt repeats
over and over and over again.
It's truly boring.
So it subtracts-- well,
remember that this
is in the same direction as Q1.
And it's better to work with Q1,
because we've found that guy.
We've got it.
And we know it's a unit vector.
So here's my linear
algebra question.
What's the component of a2
that I want to subtract off?
It's the component in
the direction of q1.
It's this in the
direction of q1.
And let me just
remember, so obviously,
that angle is coming into it.
So that will be a2
transpose q1 times q1.
That's it.
That's the component
that we remove.
And maybe I'd prefer to
write it as q1 transpose a2.
I don't know.
It doesn't matter of course.
The two dot products
are the same.
Maybe I will just--
yeah-- well, maybe not.
Fine.
Now what is that vector
supposed to achieve?
It's supposed to be this vector.
This vector I'm
really going to call
A2, because it's in the
right direction for Q2,
but it is not yet?
AUDIENCE: Normal.
GILBERT STRANG: Normal.
So what is Q2 then?
So I'm saying this guy
got the direction right.
They're saying subtract
it off this vector.
Got that direction right.
Got it as A2.
What is Q2 now that
I want to finish?
I've got the direction.
All I want to do is get
it to be a unit vector.
So I just take A2 over its norm.
That double step is the
whole thing in Gram-Schmidt,
the whole thing.
Subtract off the components
in the directions already set.
Then you get something in a
totally new direction, called
A, capital A. And then
you divide by its length
to make it a unit vector.
And that gives you the new Q.
Just to show that
we've got a point, what
about the next
step, aiming for Q3.
So tell me what A3 should be?
A3, I'm going to
start with this.
And I'm going to
subtract off some stuff.
What am I going to subtract off?
AUDIENCE: The transpose.
GILBERT STRANG: The component,
a3 transpose, right.
Times q1 q1.
And I didn't yet check so that
this came out orthogonal to q1,
but I'll come back to that.
Now, have I done everything
I should do here with a3?
No, I've got one
more step to take.
And I should take the
two steps separately.
It's called modified
Gram-Schmidt.
And what I want to do is
subtract off the q2 component.
So what multiple
of q2 do I need?
Because q2 has been set
by the time I get to a3,
so what goes here?
AUDIENCE: a3 transpose
GILBERT STRANG: a3 transpose--
AUDIENCE: q2
GILBERT STRANG: q2.
Thanks.
If you look at a code,
say a Matlab code
to do Gram-Schmidt-- oh,
what's the final q3 then?
AUDIENCE: Normalize it.
GILBERT STRANG: Normalize it.
So you take A3, which is
in the right direction,
and you divide by its
length to get a unit vector.
Let me just come back and
check that I did it right,
that I got the right direction.
So what do I mean by
the right direction?
What should I check
about that guy?
I should check that it's
inner product with q1 is?
If this is the right
direction to go,
that way, then I should check--
I have to check--
hopefully, I've got
the formula right--
that it's dot product,
inner product with q1 is--
AUDIENCE: 0.
GILBERT STRANG: 0.
Thank you.
So is it obvious that it is?
Take the inner product of the
dot product of that with q1,
what do you get?
You get the same number
q1 a2 transpose q1.
You get that number.
And over here, you're
getting q1 transpose with q1.
So do you see what I'm doing?
Probably it looks like it
would have been better.
I'm checking that q1
transpose a2 is 0.
Yeah, it is.
q1 transpose a2 here, q1
transpose a2, or a2 transpose
q1, I don't mind.
And I have another
q1 transpose q1 here.
And what is that?
What is q1 transpose q1?
It is?
AUDIENCE: 1.
GILBERT STRANG: 1.
So check.
OK, that's Gram-Schmidt,
standard Gram-Schmidt,
which you have met before.
Now, I'm ready for a
better Gram-Schmidt.
You could say a better
Gram-Schmidt, because here--
so what's it going
to be the difference?
Here, I took the a's in
their original order.
Now, suppose I did
that with elimination.
Elimination, usually we
write as acting on the row.
So thinking about elimination,
I'm thinking I'm the rows.
What would be the danger in
taking the rows in order, doing
no row exchanges, just figure
out the pivot each time,
and kill the rest of the
column and then move on?
So taking the rows in
the order they came,
whatever it might
be, what's the risk?
And why would
Matlab not do that?
Because something can be
very small and totally
blow up your calculations.
And that's that pivot number.
Sort of the question is,
if a2 is very near a1--
so let me draw a new picture.
So here's the risk.
So a1 was whatever it was.
If a2 is really close
to the same direction,
then I'm subtracting
off almost all of it,
and I've got some tiny little
bit for the new direction.
That's like the
pivot in elimination.
It's the number that
sort of measures what's
new, what the new
row in elimination
or the new column in
Gram-Schmidt gives you.
And if that's too small--
I mean, like in
elimination, as I say,
we would never use
an elimination code
on a general matrix that didn't
check the size of the pivot
and exchange rows
when necessary.
Well, similarly,
with Gram-Schmidt, it
can take the columns in order.
That's the standard Gram-Schmidt
taking the columns in order.
But only if it checks each
time that the little bit--
well, that the new part,
what would be the new part,
is big enough to be able to--
we have to divide by the thing.
And if that A2 is
tiny is a tiny vector.
This is dividing
by A2 and onwards
is building in round-off error
that we can't remove again.
We're stuck with it.
So that's the column exchange,
column pivoting idea in sort
of a more professional
Gram-Schmidt.
And to do it--
so I have to be able to
compare this little bit,
if it is little, with what?
What am I going to compare with?
In elimination, I looked
down the rest of the column
for a bigger number.
I guess what I have to do is
I have to find this component,
not just from a2, but from
all the remaining a's.
And I'll pick the biggest.
So there, in that
sentence, I said
the main idea of
column exchangers
is once you get q1 set, which
certainly q1 was the easiest
one in the world,
but maybe even for q1
I guess it could even happen.
That would be like
starting with a zero
up in the upper left corner
for elimination, like what
a way to start the day.
Here, if my matrix A
had a tiny little a1,
then I should look
for a bigger one
to get the very first q chosen.
Let's suppose-- give ourselves
a reasonable chance here--
let's suppose a1 was a decent
size, so as I've drawn.
The next step might not
be, if I use a2, as I say,
it could be same
direction as a1 virtually,
and then I'm just working
with that little piece.
So what do I have
to do differently?
I have to be able to compare
this little piece with all
the other potential
possibilities.
So let me just write
down what you have
to do in a different order.
So this is now with column
pivoting, column exchange,
column pivoting allowed,
or it's possible.
So to make it possible, I
have to find not only A2,
the piece of little a2, I
have to find a2, the piece.
I'm just going to copy that.
I have to take my second column,
subtract off the q1 part.
And that could be small.
So I have to compare it with--
oh, I haven't
written this page up.
So I haven't got a
notation in mind yet.
I won't give it a name.
I have to also compute at
this step before deciding q2--
now I'm describing how to
decide q2, the second vector.
And I'm saying that
the way to decide q2
is not only to take a piece of
a2 but also the piece of a3.
Look at this piece.
And look at all
the other pieces.
And now, what will be my policy?
Standard Gram-Schmidt
accepted this one,
and didn't look at these.
But, now, I'm going
to look at them all.
And I'm going to
take the largest.
I'm going to take the largest.
And that will be
the A2 that I want.
So it might not be this one.
If this guy is largest, then
I'm taking column 3 first.
And that will be my A2.
And then I'll say fine.
And then q2 will be
that A2 over its norm.
You see the difference?
It's not exciting.
And you might think,
wait a minute,
this is a heck of
a lot more work.
But it isn't.
It isn't actually more
work, because these
are all the things--
these ones that look like
we're paying a price,
we're computing all
these alternatives--
but we had to do that
eventually anyway.
Do you see that?
Let me just say it again.
The standard way took all the
components, like for here.
The standard way waited
until you got to column 3
and then subtracted
off both pieces,
waited until you got to column
4, subtracted off three pieces.
This way, you're subtracting
off the first piece
as soon as you know
what it should be.
As soon as you know
q1, you remove it
from all the remaining vectors.
And you look to see
what's the biggest.
You pick the biggest one.
I said maybe it's this guy.
So you move that one.
Or some permutation
matrix is going to move it
to the second column.
See, it started in
the third column,
but I'm going to move
it to the second,
because it's the biggest.
Then I do the right thing.
I find q2.
And now I go on toward q3.
And how will I find q3?
I'd want to pick the
biggest column to work with.
So I subtract off
the q2 components.
This is like easy to
say, but I had never
like figured it out before.
So let me just say it again.
And then I'll leave
that with you.
How do I get q3?
I've fixed two columns.
They happened to be,
maybe not necessarily
the first two, but two
columns, two q's are set,
and I'm looking
for the next one.
I go on and I look at all the
remaining columns, all of which
have had subtracted off
their q1 and q2 parts.
So I've orthogonalized
with respect to q1 and q2.
I look at all the
remaining things
that I have to work with
and pick the biggest.
Just like picking the biggest
number to go into the pivot.
OK, I don't think I
can say it anymore
without just repeating myself.
And I bring it here to
class, because I had not
sort of appreciated the
point that no extra work was
involved.
You just did these subtractions
for all the remaining columns
of A before you started
on the next job.
Is that OK?
Eventually the notes
will describe that.
Maybe they even do.
Yeah, I think they even do.
I wrote it but I
didn't understand it.
Now, little improvement.
So yes?
AUDIENCE: So are we
permuting every time
to get the biggest pivot?
GILBERT STRANG: Yeah.
Yeah.
Only we don't call them pivots.
Or maybe we should.
I don't know what word is
used to get the biggest
column remaining or something.
Yeah, yeah, each time.
You know, if the columns
were in a stupid order,
this puts them in
the right order.
OK, finally, come these
weird names, Krylov, Russian.
Arnoldi, actually, I
don't know what he is.
And I shouldn't
admit that on tape.
So what's the idea there?
So again, we're
solving Ax equal b.
So this is going to be Krylov.
What was his idea?
Well, I want to
solve Ax equal b.
A is a big matrix, pretty big.
Of course, I don't
plan to invert it.
That would be insane.
What I can do with a the matrix
A, especially if it's sparse--
so a large sparse A would be
a good candidate for Krylov.
So what is it that you could
do cheap and fast with a large,
I mean really large, but
really sparse matrix A?
AUDIENCE: Matrix times a vector.
GILBERT STRANG: You can do
a matrix times a vector.
And here's our matrix.
And there is our vector.
So we could start
with a vector b.
We can multiply A times b.
We can multiply A
times A times b.
And, of course, I
write it that way.
I never-- I mean, like if you
multiply A times A first, then
like you turn in
your Matlab account,
because you just have
to do it that way.
And then you keep going, which
of course is A squared b,
but you didn't form A squared.
And then on up to--
in the end, you get to some
A to say k, k minus 1 b.
But, of course, that's
computed as A times
the previous one, which was
A times the previous one.
So there is a bunch
of vectors, which
are likely to be independent.
So they span a space.
And it's called
the Krylov space.
So these span.
They're combinations.
Combinations give--
oh, I don't like
that letter k, because
that's also Krylov,
so what shall I say? j.
So I have j vectors.
The original b, Ab, A
squared b, up to that.
So combinations give the
Krylov space, say, we'll
name it after Krylov and
we need a subscript j
to show how big it
is, its dimension.
So that will be the idea.
Well, let me complete the idea.
The idea will be--
there are combinations.
So that's a space, a subspace,
pretty big if j is big.
And I'm going to look for the
best solution in that space.
So I'm not going to solve
of Ax equals b exactly.
I'm going to find the
best solution, the closest
solution, the least squares
solution in this Krylov space.
I'm going to let
j be pretty big.
So this space has got
plenty of vectors in it.
I have a basis for this space.
And some combination of these
basis vectors will be my xj.
So, again, xj will be the best
vector, or the closest vector
in this Krylov space, j,
It will be the best vector
in that space, the closest one.
So I know what the space is.
I've reduced the
dimension down to j.
And I can find this best vector.
There's just one catch.
And it's the same
catch that Gram-Schmidt
were aiming to help to remove.
That is this basis that I'm--
right now, I'm working with
all combinations of these guys.
And those could be
very, very dependent.
That might be a terrible basis.
Anytime you want to
do big computations,
what kind of a
basis do you want?
Yes?
So what sort of a basis
is good to project onto
to find the best solution
within that subspace?
So we're sort of
finding a projection.
And you've got vectors
that span the space.
So you know what
you're projecting onto.
But those vectors, they
might be nearly dependent.
They might all be pointing
almost the same direction.
In which case, your
calculations are terrible.
So what do you do?
Orth-- Orthogonalize.
And that's where
Arnoldi comes in.
And there's also a
Hungarian guy named Lanczos.
So that's what they
contribute is how
to orthogonalize that basis.
And then, once you've done that,
you have an orthogonal basis.
And, of course, an
orthogonal basis
is perfect to do a projection.
Everybody has to know that.
Why is a orthogonal
basis so great?
Ortho-normal even.
Let's just remember.
Suppose I have a vector x.
It's unknown here.
But suppose I have it.
And I want to write
it as a combination
of these ortho-normal guys.
say, n.
What is it about all
ortho-normal q's that
makes this easy to
do, which it would not
be with an arbitrary basis?
So this is really
Q times c, right?
Q times this vector of C's.
The q's are in the columns of
Q. The c's were multiplying
a matrix by a vector.
It's a combination
of the columns.
That's what we get.
And when the q's are
orthogonal, what's the answer?
We can get the
answer straight away.
So here, we're trying to find
the coefficients with respect
to the basis vectors
Q of a given vector x.
And what's the answer
to that question?
The point is, usually, to
find the coefficients, c would
have to be Q inverse x.
We'd have to solve that
system of equations.
We do have to solve that
But where's the payoff
from ortho-normal basis?
AUDIENCE: Q inverse--
GILBERT STRANG: Q
inverse is Q transpose.
That's the payoff.
So it's just telling
me that to find c1--
how do I find c1?
This says take the first
q1, transpose with x.
I'll say the same thing here.
Take the first vector with x.
That will be about
cq, q1, transpose q1.
I'm just taking the dot product
of everything there with q1.
And then a c2, q1
transpose, q2 and so on.
But what's good?
AUDIENCE: You have zeros.
GILBERT STRANG: Tell me again.
AUDIENCE: The other
ones are zeros.
GILBERT STRANG:
These are all zero.
And the q1 transpose q1 is?
AUDIENCE: 1.
GILBERT STRANG: 1.
So it's perfect.
c1 is q1 transpose x.
And that's exactly
what that tells us.
The first component
is the first row
of q transpose, which
is q1 transpose with x.
So that's the idea.
So that's the idea here.
That's the reason for
Arnoldi and Lanczos
being famous is that they
figured out a good way
to orthogonalize that basis.
Do we want to see what they did?
Or those would be in the notes.
Well, how do you do it?
So this is the basis.
This is our not good basis.
And then our good basis
is going to be q's.
So I'll take b to
be-- q1 will be what?
What would be the
right choice for q1?
Well, I'll take that first
vector and normalize it.
We're just doing Gram-Schmidt.
What would q2 be?
How would I find q2 following
the Gram-Schmidt idea?
I take Ab.
I subtract off its component
in this q1 direction
and I normalize.
And all the Arnoldi
Lanczos algorithm
is is that same
Gram-Schmidt idea applied
to these Krylov vectors.
So Arnoldi-Lanczos-- Arnoldi
is for any matrix and Lanczos
is for a symmetric matrix where
you get some special benefit.
So what they did,
you could say now,
they just wrote
down Gram-Schmidt,
in fact, probably the
standard Gram-Schmidt,
because this is a
case where we really
don't want to exchange columns.
I don't want suddenly to
be pushed into this one.
I'd rather take them in
order, because it just
turns out right.
And this is in the notes.
So let me tell
you where this is.
It will be Section II.1.
So Part 2 of the book,
which is where we are,
and the first section.
So what all together is
in this first section when
you look at it?
That section is standard
numerical linear algebra,
what any course in
MIT offers, 18.3--
I'm not sure of the number, 330
maybe, which is, of all things
like this.
Krylov would be there,
Arnoldi, Lanczos.
Of course, Gram and
Schmidt would be there.
That's five people who've
thought of the same thing.
And so that Section
II.1 summarizes
what's in really good,
well, a lot of textbooks.
And let me mention a favorite,
a book by Trefethen and Bau.
Or the "Bible."
So this is maybe a
moment to tell you
about two books on classical
numerical linear algebra, what
do you do for matrices
of order 1,000,
not for matrices
of order millions.
That you have to rethink.
So Trefethen-Bau isn't called
numerical linear algebra.
And do you know the
authors of the Bible
of numerical linear algebra?
So that's a textbook.
And what I'm going to
write down now finally
is 750 pages it's grown
to in its fourth edition.
It's the Bible for all
numerical linear algebra people.
And it's written by
Golub and VanLoan.
So Gene Golub was
a remarkable guy.
He probably didn't write more
than about 11 pages of this.
Charlie wrote most of it.
But Golub was an
amazing person who
traveled the world
and connected people
and left behind
papers to be written
and books to be written.
And so this Golub-VanLoan
is now in the fourth volume.
And it has so much good stuff
and references that it's
like the good reference.
And this is the
good textbook if you
were going to teach a course
on numerical linear algebra.
So I think that I've come
to the point to finish.
So I really have finished
along with the extra attraction
of this different problem,
I finished with Ax equal b.
And, well, at least,
I now move onto what
to do with really,
really large matrices.